welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and thor love and thunder ended with the
sad god turning into a dad god finally
getting a new family after his old
family went stab sparkle and pop in the
form of gore the godbutcher's daughter
who gore named the most beautiful name
of all time nothing absolutely nothing
oh
she literally has no name you know other
than the symbolic names core gives both
her and her uncle four at the end of the
film but what if i told you that love
isn't going to be her name forever what
if i told you that marvel studios was
trying to sneakily insert a new and
popular classic avenger into the mcu
right under your very nose holes well
let me tell you all who that secret
someone could be my nerd babies but
first please head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our newest
shirt inspired by thor love and thunder
it's super amazing and i love it like i
love all of our shirts and also have our
miss marvel shirt that is also equally
as amazing so head on over to new
rutgersmerch.com today to pick up both
of these shirts so you can be rocking
around in style alright so if you
thought that professor xavier was the
baddest bald [ __ ] think again my nerd
babies because that title has got to
belong to that of the powerful moon
dragon of the marvel comics one of the
most powerful members of the avengers
roster and exactly who i believe this
little sassy girl is at the very end of
thor love and thunder and i also believe
that taiko at tt and marvel studios
secretly laid down hints as to why this
is the case but first if you're not
familiar with moondragon from the comics
moondragon is the daughter of drax the
destroyer who ends up being taken in by
thanos's father alars after thanos kills
both of heather's parents and that he
couldn't handle raising another child
after his massive failure of a purple
planet purging people beating son alars
also known as mentor would send heather
to live and train amongst the monks of
titan where heather would shave her head
bald and go through the most intense
scientific and meditation trainings by
these eternal monks on the moon of titan
transforming her normal human brain into
one of the most powerful telepaths in
the marvel comics universe one that can
do crazy ass [ __ ] like enslave an entire
planet or even restore daredevil's sight
with just her mind shit's insane man and
her extensive first-hand titanium
education on science and martial arts
earned heather the title of titan's most
renowned scientist and titan's most
skilled female warrior but heather would
not come to name herself moondragon
until her mind became psychically linked
with a dark dragon that lived buried
within titan itself that secretly imbued
her with dark power and this connection
also allows moon dragon to turn into a
dragon form now why does this matter
with thor iv and where are those hints
the taiko attitude planted that point
towards this well first of all while
thor is tying her shoes we can see that
love is playing with a dragon that she
made with love even making a roaring
gesture with her free hand at that
dragon like ah
like as soon as i saw that dragon in her
hand i was like yep my suspicions have
been confirmed feige is doing a moon
dragon because in the comics moon dragon
regularly struggles with the influence
of this dark dragon on her mind and that
influence would sometimes turn moon
dragon into a super cruel version of
herself that would sometimes fight the
avengers so love growling at that dragon
with her hand is sort of symbolic in
that way and this darker side of moon
dragon is represented perfectly by
taikuatiti when love gets into a
disagreement with thor during breakfast
her eyes glowed purple before shooting
out a purple cosmic blast at thor this
power is what i believe is the dark moon
dragon power that marvel studios is
setting up for love to conquer as her
mcu story continues post war love and
thunder because i believe that gore the
god butcher in his final wish at the
heart of eternity gave his daughter some
of his dark cosmic power to protect
herself as he knew that he would no
longer be around to do so because
remember that really interesting fight
gore the god butcher had with valkyrie
four and the other four on that moon
when those dark dragony beings started
coming out of it that's the bone dragon
power gore put inside his love to
protect what he was seeking the entire
time giving her eyes a purple glow which
is a glow that is associated with your
darker entities of the mcu like your
agathas and your reliance love losing
her temper and attacking thor in that
way is super crucial to what is coming
next for love in future mcu installments
because much like moon dragon in the
comics love will have to learn how to
control her emotion-fueled powers
through intense meditation which is why
i believe eternity is revealed to be a
cosmic crisscross applesauce
[ __ ] because eternity was
meditating and now that love seems to
have a piece of eternity within her
along with her father's dark power she
will definitely have to master
meditation just like eternity and her
comic book counterpart and also as an
aside purple is also the color of the
heather flower a type of flower that can
grow and thrive in even the most barren
of land in a name that i believe thor
will be naming his new nameless niece in
the near future because gore's daughter
was the life that grew and survived in
that dried-up wasteland of a planet but
anyways let's take a look at that scene
of love as she eats breakfast and gets
ready for a day of beating aliens with
her god uncle thor because the weirdest
thing about that breakfast scene other
than you know thor in an apron is seeing
love having a light read on gravity's
influence on time travel in the mcu and
the quantum mechanics that come with it
in the form of jane foster's book the
foster theory which is you know
not the berenstein bear like this weird
little 10 year old girl after being
resurrected and cosmically altered by
eternity is now able to understand the
complexities of gravitational wormholes
exhibiting a heightened intelligence
like heather douglas did in the comics
while training under the gods of titan
also let's take a look at love's clothes
here because i believe that she wears
all green as a nod to moondragon's color
of choice in the comics with the color
purple on her outfit representing her
new powers and i also believe that
having her hood with two eye holes cut
out over her face while reading is also
a piece of foreshadowing to moon dragon
and her own green covered eyes also i
really love the detail of how she has
rainbow hearts on her pants not only to
represent how she his love but also
because moondragon was one of marvel's
first openly gay heroes in comics she is
a badass bisexual who is in a very close
relationship with the avenger quasar who
also just sort of just got
semi-confirmed in the mcu canon with
that statue of eon being introduced
right outside the doors where moondragon
was to be born with the power of both
eternity and her father so all in all
i'm pretty convinced that thor love and
thunder is setting up those seeds for
moon dragon in the mcu especially with
all those dragons on that moon and
dragons coming to the mcu in general and
love getting training from the gods in
her own way in the mcu like moondragon
did in the comics but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter most importantly you can follow
new rockstars wherever we are on social
media do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com you can pick up our
newest four and miss marvel inspired
latest obsession shirts they're not
gonna be around forever to pick them up
today but again i love you guys so much
thank you guys for watching and spending
time with me and i'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you